The joe rogan experience.
Yeah.
I always assumed we would be hanging
out all the time from now on from,
from that point on.
But it really didn't work out that way.
No,
no,
it never does,
you know?
No.
Yeah,
that's true because everybody
goes in such different directions.
I've ran into Maura a once or twice.
I know rents are once we had a good time
at one of those NBC functions and I was
on Newsradio or fear factor and she
was on er and we got drunk together.
It was a great time.
It was all like the old days.
The mind is always fun to get drunk.
Oh yeah.
She's one of the best ever.
You know,
she was the one who convinced me
to kick in the craft service door.
We're all hungry.
Uh,
yeah.
We had some good times on
that set after the set.
After filming,
we would basically just drink all night,
you know,
filming would be done at whatever and we
all have our mini fridge is stocked in
our coolers and we would just get hammered
and just shoot the shit and have fun
and laugh and go over Dave's room
and listen to some weird music.
Dave always had some weird chicks that
made you want to cry laying in a few of
them.
The dated.
Yeah.
Just,
you know,
strange,
somber women voices and a,
and then we,
yeah,
somebody would be there till,
till it was time to go to Denny's.
Right.
Or we would go to a,
down the street when we
were at sunset Gower,
we would go down to that bar.
What was it called?
There was like a liquor in the industry
bar look really catered to people that
were leaving the set.
Well,
the,
well,
right next to the
peanut.
Was that what it was?
Yeah,
it was to be the Columbia bar and grill.
yeah,
yeah.
I'd be like all the people from
a Fraser and a dal is weird.
It'd be there.
Yeah.
Go.
And he wouldn't be stiff as fuck.
We would be hammered and they would be
all still like doing their actor thing.
You know,
I thought it was a marvelous performance.
I think he was quite lovely.
Did you know that it's on Broadway now.
I'll,
I'll be amazing.
I've got to see it.
You know,
they were just all completely full of
shit and he would come in and try and grab
everybody's Dick and you know,
Dave and I would be
hammered more hammered.
Yeah.
And Julie being and certainly being,
yeah,
we'd all be laughing and joking around.
Yeah.
It was a great,
great group of humans.
That was one of the most
fun times of my entire life,
those years.
It was amazing.
There was one time I remember
we were about to go and do it.
There was a live audience there
and everybody was getting written,
getting ready and we were standing in
that little back hallway where they would
introduce us and I said,
you know,
that this is going to
be one of those days.
We're going to look back,
uh,
when we're older and we're going to go,
I can't believe I didn't enjoy this more.
I can't believe I didn't
appreciate how crazy.
This is more.
You don't realize what a random stroke
of luck it is to get so many cool people
all together in one group.
Yeah.
The fact that yeah,
we all want it to spend time together.
Uh,
like,
like when work was done,
nobody wanted to go.
Everyone wanted to stay.
We'd also get the feeds from other,
other,
um,
oh yeah.
The other shows and other sets we
get to watch other horrible sitcoms.
Greg Geraldo had had a show
that was a good one actually.
Yeah.
And so to Joey Lawrence,
do you remember that?
Oh,
I only,
I mostly just remember him sitting in his
convertible playing his own cds really
loud.
He always had bad ass cars.
Like Joey Lawrence always had like the
newest Ferrari or the newest Bentley or
whatever the hell it was.
But he'd sit there playing
his own music loud,
super loud with a Bandanna on.
Where is he now?
Man.
Intentionally ripped jeans.
He was just in dancing
with the stars recently?
Well I think Dave said it best even
back then was that someone needs to tell
that young man that he's gay.
And that's exactly how you said it too.
We stopped and we were looking there
and there was a couple of them and you,
you just,
you just stopped and paused and said,
someone needs to tell
that young man he's gay.
We went into work.
I mean he would be right.
You don't know where these,
where these cars were parked and right
directly in front of the building.
So you'd open up the door and you know,
you basically be on the set and right
behind that is this fucking guy in his car
blaring his own music from
isn't some insane stereo system.
It's like,
and if your music is the is great,
it's wrong to sit there and listen
to your own music in the car.
Yeah.
Robert Plant is in his car fucking
beating the drums to his steering wheel.
It'd be like,
what the fuck?
Robbery.
Really?
You don't get enough attention.
But when you,
Joey Lawrence,
now you've just started
to stand up recently,
which is a fascinating thing to me because
I always thought you'd be a brilliant
standing up because you're a great writer.
And when we used to do those
little things in the audience,
you remember where we would talk to the
audience before you would fuck around
with them every now and then
and you wouldn't like do it.
Like Phil had a routine that he was doing,
like Phil actually started
doing standup because of,
you know,
wanting to entertain the audience.
So he had a bunch of bits that he would
do like Clinton impressions and they
were really good and it was like,
I'm just like,
Holy Shit Dude.
You're like a real comic.
Like you're a standup.
It's like Kinda thinking about doing.
Phil was like this really
unusual human being.
Very,
very fascinating guy.
Yeah.
He was the world.
He was like a great hobbyist.
Yeah.
He would go so deep.
He will,
he got into flying,
which is actually how I found
out about this neighborhood.
You know,
fill a,
was taking me out into
the valley looking for,
you know,
different places where he could,
go and have a nice view.
You know,
we went up in this little
single engine plane,
but I remember when he first
started getting into the flying boy,
he was reading book after
book in between rehearsals.
He'd be studying his pilot's book
like they've done with the little fake
broadcast booth.
Yeah.
Very.
He was very,
very disciplined.
He would,
well he said Phil was like a big league
version of Mark McKinney from kids in
the hall.
Smart Bikini was really into
his flight simulator bill.
Learn to fly a plane,
you know,
loved it.
He learned to fly a plane.
He learned to sail a boat.
You know,
he was one of those guys,
you know,
he's a,
if only he had learned to duck mobile.
Not even if you learn to just separate
from fucking crazy people I know had
some,
we,
you know,
we all did,
I think had talks with him
many times about divorce.
You know,
like you got to get out of that man.
Yeah.
It was one of those things where we would,
uh,
we would have these parties.
I mean,
Paul had one party once and I remember
we were all at this bar somewhere and
Phil showed up with the wife and she was
saying the creepiest shit insulting him
and you know,
talking about how she likes pickup
trucks because they reminder of,
you know,
boys that she used to bang back
when she was younger and just,
just,
just torturing him,
just torture and talking about,
oh well you're not fail.
You know,
it feels too old and he's just like
women thrown on him all the time.
It seems like if he was miserable
that you would have just,
it doesn't matter man,
when you have children with somebody,
you're inexorably attached forever.
Was the thought of being separated from
his kids and I understand because at the
time I was separated from my kids.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I know.
You know,
I completely see where he was coming from.
He didn't want a divorce.
He thought his wife is with all her flaws,
was still very good to
the kids and you know,
and he felt,
felt like he could work it out
and then he really got into pot,
you know,
that was his thing.
He would just get,
he's lazy.
Yeah,
I was luck.
Yeah.
You'd be sitting in his Mercedes in the
parking space with his one hitter baked
baked to the gills stone.
And you weren't smoking weed,
smoking weed with Phil Hartman.
That would barely,
yeah.
Yeah.
You didn't do any,
any drugs?
Just get drunk.
And so I would do,
people don't know,
a lot of people don't even
realize news radio wasn't a hit,
but why we were on the air.
We were on the air.
We moved nine times,
nine times over the
course of five seasons.
And the guy had the
head of programming at,
at,
uh,
scheduling at NBC.
Hated us.
Why was that?
I don't know.
Remember,
there's that whole thing with,
uh,
the rolling stone article.
Uh,
but that was when we
were already floundering.
But it was also,
but the guy,
this guy,
uh,
we should tell people what that means.
What's the rolling the rolling start out.
Nicole Paul Stanley or Paul Stanley.
Yeah.
Kiss Paul Simms,
who was the creator of the show called,
uh,
nbcs Thursday night lineup,
which was their big friends lineup.
They called it a shit sandwich.
He called.
It was really,
it should have been shit was the bun
because they're real sandwich was friends
and then you would have friends on and
then you would have this terrible show
and it was always on after friends.
And obviously NBC was very upset that
Paul was calling sex in the city or the
single guy to pieces of shit.
But you know,
they were,
they were terrible shows.
And then friends was as brilliant
show that everybody tuned into.
So they sort of watch those other
shows just because they were on.
But I guess it guy,
the cantors,
Preston Beckmann hated our show.
Even when we did the pilot,
he didn't want it picked up well because
we were originally supposed to get a
Thursday slot ourselves.
But this guy who was in charge of the
MVC schedule wouldn't let us have it
Thursday slot.
So then he basically kept trying
to find a slot that would kill us.
So that's why they put us on,
uh,
what we are the leading we're,
we're on with wings and Fraser,
uh,
phrasing and those shows were both doing
poorly when we came along and he put us
on with those shows and we are our,
we boosted the ratings of both shows.
Well all of sudden it became
like a decent lineup for,
for comedies,
but it was a different time then man.
There was no dvrs and
shows couldn't exist in a,
in a non popular spot.
It had to be a spot where people
are already looking for the ratings.
We were getting in those,
we're getting like 10 million people
tuning in and those ratings and those days
were considered a ratings failure.
Like today,
if you've got those ratings here,
the number one show on TV,
it's weird.
And then because there's
so many channels now,
at one point in time,
uh,
Lou Martin used to show up at our writer's
meetings at the rather at the table
read was t with a t shirt on with
the number of whatever we were in,
what place are in.
And he showed up and it was
84 84th place and we're like,
what was it,
84 88 and my name.
And that's when,
when they finally,
when they,
they put us up against Drew Carey and
we have Warren Littlefield actually came
down to a table read to let us
know that they still loved us.
They surface Turkey dinner.
Oh,
you never learn or like there was there
carving Turkey and Warren Littlefield
who was a nice guy or a network head.
Yeah.
He was very nice.
This,
I always remember a 95 Warren Littlefield
dancing on the bar in New York at when
we went for the upfronts and it was like
Jay Leno had had just hit number was
the number one late night show.
Wow.
And have more of a standing on
this bar doing shots and shouting.
19 nine.
Oh Wow.
Again,
that's hilarious.
Was that the one where,
which one did you guys get drunk at?
I didn't go and you guys
get the rock every event.
But we got kicked out where
we weren't allowed to go.
It was at the Sag awards.
These motherfuckers got so hammered.
They caused so much
damage at the sag awards.
We couldn't go anymore.
We weren't allowed to go.
I've still never been back.
Here's a great one.
And we were at the Emmy's and this is
after Phil had been murdered and we're
sitting there and you know,
Phil was nominated for something and,
uh,
the,
the nominations go and I
think the guy from Frasier,
God,
David Hyde Pierce and
Dave turns to me and goes,
what does Phil have to do to win?
Like,
oh no,
you know,
it was so,
it was in David.
David Hyde Pierce looks so
embarrassed to be winning.
He was literally up there,
like,
is all the blood drained out of his face?
He was just going,
um,
well obviously Phil Hartman and um,
you know,
and he didn't,
he couldn't even put a sentence together.
He was wonder what the
choice behind that was.
That was weird.
I don't know.
Don't,
don't kill someone and then expect them
to win sort of message you're sending
out to Burger's eating.
It's cheating.
Being murdered as a cheat.
Oh,
what a strange,
strange times.
So what did you guys do at the Sag
awards that got us kicked out forever?
I think,
uh,
most you're just,
at the time I guess,
cause we all thought what
a stupid awards show,
you know,
just the first year of the SAG awards.
And we said this is ridiculous.
Why actors voting about
other and giving awards,
saying who's best.
That's the,
you know,
our union is deciding who is
best and it creates this weird,
this like culture of
ass kissing and fakery.
They're all like,
what a wonderful project.
You know,
an amazing,
and I think what we do,
I think more,
and I found where the,
uh,
the,
the service bar was and you would have
had like the big industrial corkscrew and
everything sweet.
So we're going back there just opening
up bottles of wine and bringing them up
to the table and I think,
you know,
and then,
we had to Andy with this too.
Yeah.
Uh,
which was so who did what and we do
anything notable that got us kicked out.
Uh,
I don't really remember.
I think we were just
noisy and rude and uh,
stealing.
We were applauding inappropriately and
he's really where it was a cast where you
regularly hear people say,
you know what might joke doesn't work.
We should cut my joke that
his joke is the better joke.
Yes.
All the time.
You know,
it was really amazing environment.
And you would also hear,
don't put that pencil in my cunt.
I mean,
yeah,
I would just say the
most fucked up shit ever.
I mean if we were,
do you remember the time we had the,
we actually had to sit down and we,
we,
they played that presentation for us.
Oh the,
uh,
the sex sexual harassment.
Oh,
I felt so badly for that
person read it was that,
you don't know,
you don't know the group of people
you've just walked in front of.
It was so ridiculous.
They have to go over this whole thing
of what's appropriate and what's not
appropriate.
And it would have meant basically what
it cut down about 98% of all conversation
on our sex.
I mean we all just sort of,
uh,
you know,
just made an agreement that
we wouldn't so each other
like,
okay
fly.
Right.
Cause what if anybody wanted to,
I mean there's been many
times on sets where,
uh,
you know,
especially women,
actresses feel like there's too much of
that shit going on and they just fucking
fuck this.
I'm getting a lawyer and
then there's payouts.
Man.
It becomes like a big issue.
You make a lot of money.
I know cause everyone like eat have Andy
and you'd be sitting there at to Vicki
Guy,
they get us on stuff.
Your pussy leaves mud.
Vicky.
Vicky would be laughing the very
first time I met Andy again,
I'd been acting for a fucking month.
Right?
I'd done no new,
no one like that.
I grew up with fighters and pool hustlers.
The,
those are the two worlds that I was
most entrenched in and crazy standup
comedians.
They're all nuts,
right?
And then all of a sudden I'm in this,
this dressing room with Andy and Andy is
sitting cross legged and he has clogs.
Okay.
And he's got these weird brown corduroy
pants and he's like flipping his foot
back and forth.
He goes,
do you think you're going to be famous?
And I was like,
I don't know.
What do you think?
Oh yes,
I know I'm going to be,
now I'm going to be,
I've already decided I'm
going to be so famous.
I can't wait.
I can't wait to be really,
really famous to think this is
going to be the show for you.
Or maybe like,
I don't know,
man.
I don't know.
You gotta be famous Amos from this.
Yeah.
I think it's already happening.
I think the arc of your friendship with
Andy was the most interesting of the
whole cast.
It only wish I hadn't marijuana back then.
Yeah.
I would have found him so
much more fascinating because
I had a testosterone and
adrenaline and that was just every
day was just don't kill Andi.
Don't be,
don't fucking kill him.
Cause he was just so out of control.
I've never met someone so out of control,
but on set.
Nobody enjoyed Andy more than you did.
I loved him.
Like,
and scenes like Joe had so much trouble
getting through scenes with Angie cause
they would laugh.
He would bust you up constantly.
I can't just say that,
I guess,
but my,
my emotional attachment
though to news radio is that,
that is fucked up is he is,
he'll always,
I'll always consider him to be family.
You know,
like everyone from news radio,
I always considered to me
everyone from these radios,
you know,
his family to me.
Yeah.
You know?
Yeah,
no doubt.
It's,
it's,
it's a very unusual bond that we all have.
You know,
Steven road call me a while back for
some party that he was throwing and I
couldn't make it.
I was going out of town and I was like,
wow,
how good is it to talk to this guy again?
Yeah.
And I feel like,
I think some of this,
we won't see each other for years,
you know?
But it's like,
but it never feels like,
but whenever I see anyone from news radio,
it doesn't feel like any time is pat.
Ah.